je ne suis pas sûr que cette réforme
soit en réalité très utile et en tout
cas pas celle là c'est de la com comme
disait à dornach c'est du populisme bcbg
c'est à dire c'est à dire que on donne à
l'opinion ce qu'elle veut entendre et on
essaye de la flatté par en offrant en
pâture le sénat l'assemblée et en les
montrant désignant les parlementaires
comme la source de tous les maux ça le
populisme bcbg que vous décrivez oui
parce que c'est quand même récurrent
chez emmanuel macron c'est qu'ils
désignent les élus locaux nationaux
comme finalement ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui et donc il faudrait
évidemment les réduire en réduire le
nombre
mais ce faisant corvette on a quoi
va-t-on parvenir on va parvenir à des
parlementaires qui vont couvrir parfois
plusieurs départements quand on cherche
au contraire à rapprocher l'élu de la
population lui va l'éloigner de deux
façons à la fois en discussion très
grande et donc vous aurez des gens qui
ne connaîtront même pas les gens qui les
ont mandatés et puis il veut faire élire
une partie de l'assemblée à la
proportionnelle ce qui va avoir pour
effet d'avoir des gens qui ne seront
plus et lui en réalité mais qui sont
désignés par leur parti et qui seront
nommés en fait à l'assemblée et d'un
proportionnelle c'est pas une bonne idée
non ce n'est pas une bonne idée n'est
pas une bonne idée parce que ça détache
progressivement les élus d'un territoire
à vous j'ai pourtant vraiment tendu ça
pendant la corvée parfois de mauvaises
idées qu'il faut les reprendre besoin de
moi je suis là je suis partisan en fait
deux choses très simples je veux que un
élu puisse avoir un territoire sur
lequel qui soit suffisamment d'actions
importants mais qui ne soit pas trop
grand pour qu'il puisse connaître
d'une certaine façon chaque commune
chaque chaque habitant c'est être
exagérément fin qu'il puisse avoir ce
lien de proximité qui permet d'avoir un
lien et trois mois je oui pendant cinq
ans depuis cinq ans je suis élu chaque
semaine en étant dans ma circonscription
en étant au contact des uns et des
autres j
tout ce que j'ai découverte que j'ai
apprise et des choses que j'ai compris
aussi par ce canal là le jour où j'aurai
une circonscription qui fera le double
ou le triple qu'est ce que je ferais je
ferais je volerais d'un endroit à
l'autre
vous avez entendu laurent wauquiez cette
semaine qui parlait d' emmanuel macron
comme quelqu'un qui n'aime pas la
province je résume un peu ses propos
c'est d'accord donc avec laurent
wauquiez non je ne suis pas d'accord
avec les l'excès de laurent wauquiez
laurent wauquiez qui on est quasiment à
convoquer les arguments de l'anti france
ce qui me paraît totalement extravagants
et qui aurait pont à des logiques de
campagne interne j'imagine sur les duels
quasiment oui ça c'est absurde ce qui ne
l'est ce qui l'est moins c'est que
effectivement emmanuel macron est un
président qui est qui a été élu va être
passé par la case élu local lui
nationale etc et donc il ne connaît pas
la mission le rôle d'un élu
il les a rencontrés que à l'elysée est
en réalité quand ils circulent en france
il circule entouré de caméras et il n'a
jamais fait ce que qu'ils examinent de
quoi pour vous ça c'est le signe d'une
méconnaissance et malheureusement ça se
sent régulièrement dans les décisions
qu'il prend c'est à dire que on sent
bien que ce qui guide sa pensée se sont
finalement c'est la doxa de bercy depuis
vingt ou trente ans et le but 20 ou 30
ans un bercy propose à chaque ministre
qui arrivent les mêmes propositions
jusqu'ici on a toujours eu des ministres
de droite ou de gauche qui ont résisté à
cette pression pas toujours mais souvent
hélas tous quittés dans les placards
ressort et acéré voie rue commerciale
pouvoir bain bercy a pris le pouvoir
effectivement aujourd'hui jeudi bercy
après le pouvoir
bercy a pris le pouvoir et derrière
emmanuel macron c'est la machine
versailles s'est déployée